believe it or not in today's video I'm
going to teach you guitarists how to
play from a 400 year old loot manuscript
in my last video we learned all about
the history of tablature and that it was
actually the dominant type of notation
used for loot's guitars the orbos and
more from 1400 to 1800 and we also
learned that there are so many digitized
manuscripts out there books and books of
music that you can play from so today
I've picked a very easy but very sad and
beautiful piece called Mr dowling's
midnight by the famous Elizabethan loot
player John dowland by the end of this
video my hope is to teach you how to
play directly from the 400 year old man
script before we dive in if you missed
the last video on the history of
tablature I'd highly recommend starting
with that one there's a link for the
video in the description now for today's
video It Doesn't Matter What type of
guitar you have electric steel string
flamenco jazz acoustic classical they'll
all work as long as I have six strings
now real quick in case you're not
familiar tablature is the main type of
notation used by guitars to play rock
pop Folk and other styles of guitar it's
super super easy you have six horizontal
lines representing this six strings of
the guitar the line on top represents
your thinnest string the first string
High e
the bottom line represents the low E the
sixth string we put numbers on those
lines which represent the Frets so if I
had a zero on the top line that would be
the first string open if I put a 1 on
the top line that would be the first
fret on the first string two is second
fret 3 is third four five six hopefully
you get the idea if understanding modern
guitar tab is new to you I'd encourage
you to go check out other videos which
teach this topic and then come back here
when you're ready and if you understand
modern guitar tab then today is going to
be easy for you so here's our piece Mr
Donald's midnight on a loot it sounds
like this
[Music]
foreign
foreign as you can see it's sad short
and beautiful while this manuscript of
French tablature might look difficult
let me just quickly show you what this
would look like in modern tap suddenly
the music looks not so difficult and
while you could play just from this you
could then only play one piece I want to
give you the tools so you can play all
loot music from the manuscript now if
you watch my history of tablature video
you'll notice that we still have six
lines here in our manuscript these six
lines represent the strings and they're
in the same orientation the one at the
top is the first string our high a
string in this case then we have letters
representing Frets instead of numbers
this is called French tablature so if we
were on the first string a is the open
first string zero B is the first fret c
d e f and we don't need anything higher
than F the fifth fret for this piece now
before we start plucking out some notes
we need to change one thing about your
guitar so it can become a loot our third
string on a guitar is G but to play all
of the beautiful flute music you see
from 1400 to 1600 all you have to do is
take your third string and bring it down
to F sharp the easiest way to do that is
to play your open second string and then
to play the fifth fret on the third
string and make those sound the same so
normally it would sound like this and
then you can tune it your third string
down
until
they sound good together now your third
string is an F sharp and from here on
out we can forget about note names and
Harmony on all that of course the next
step in your musical practice will be to
understand the notes and the harmony but
just to play the piece we don't need it
now the next thing we need to quickly
explain is that in the manuscript the
letters that look like an R are actually
C's so those are all second Frets also
this little squiggle here is an F in
different manuscripts you'll see
different handwriting and we have to get
used to the person's handwriting about
what they mean when but to be honest you
get used to this really fast when you
look through a whole book and once you
know what symbols mean which letter it's
very easy we can officially now play our
first chord we have a note on the fifth
string So reading from the the bottom to
the top fifth string we have that R
remember that means C so fifth string is
an open a on the guitar
a b c is the second fret so C on the
second fret with your thumb plucking in
the right hand then I see two A's above
that an A on the third string an A on
the second string and because they're
vertically aligned it means we should
play all those at the same time
I should note that you're going to have
to use the fingers on your right hand to
pluck using a pick isn't going to work
we're going to worry about Rhythm later
but let's keep learning some notes after
that first chord we then have a r on the
second string remember that's a c so I'm
going to call it a c for now on so
second fret on the second string I'd
play that with my middle finger of my
left hand so so far
[Music]
more about the other markings in a bit
but let's get playing a bit more the
third note says D on the second string
so a b c d That's our third fret
[Music]
and now another open second string
so the first measure
[Music]
the second measure starts in a similar
way we still have our index finger down
on this second fret of the fifth string
open third string and now we have to
play a d
the third fret of the second string next
is an open first string
followed by an open third string a and a
c on the which is the second fret of the
second string those are vertically
aligned again so we play them together
I'm playing with i and m index and
middle in the right hand
so the second measure
and the last note of the second measure
is a b so a is open B is the first fret
of the fifth string the second measure
again
foreign
let's do two whole measures very slowly
ready
go
[Music]
if I'm playing too fast or slow go ahead
and use the gear icon at the bottom to
speed up or slow down based on your
needs the third measure is almost the
same as the first one
except at the end the fourth beat we
have a c again the second fret of the
second string and an open fifth string
they're vertically aligns they play
together okay three measures in a row
ready go
[Music]
foreign
last measure of the a section we have
this chord
so we have a d on the sixth string a b c
d d is the third fret B on the third
string D on the second string at this
point if you're thinking man reading
this manuscript is so hard because the
letters are hard to read here is a
modern version of the exact same thing
we're seeing I'll make this downloadable
so again on that third measure
simultaneous so it's a chord
followed by an open first string a
and we have another chord
second fret of the sixth string that's a
c then we have e on the third string so
a b c d e and then we have the first and
the second string have a c on them
second Frets so
you can plug in the right hand thumb
index middle ring and we have to Bar
everything in the left hand
good news we have four measures let's
play them ready go
[Music]
how beautiful is that you're playing
from a 400 year old manuscript so if you
got this far give yourself a pat on the
back already I don't know about you but
I think this is so cool and it's a
beautiful experience you might be
noticing that for the chords I
arpeggiate I roll the chords rather than
playing chunk
this is called rolling accord or
arpeggiating and it can be a really nice
effect on the guitar or the loot
foreign
word arpeggio is actually what inspired
the name for my online music school
rpajanto this is an online school for
plucked instruments and if you'd like to
learn a plucked instrument like Guitar
ukulele bass loot or more or delve
deeper into the subject of tablature we
have an assortment of specialists in
various instruments and styles who can
give you weekly lessons on Zoom so
please check out ourpajato.com to learn
more now the second section we can call
it the B section is almost the same as
the first it's a variation on the first
section so it starts the same but then
you're actually seeing the manuscript
there's an a written below the staff
here we went into a problem some loots
in the Renaissance had seven strings so
in this case that's the seventh string
it would have sounded like a low D the
easiest solution when you see things
like this is just to either not play it
or take it up the octave in this case
it's the same note as this first thing
you play but you don't have the lower
version so we can just play this twice
and get a similar effect
now loots from the Renaissance to the
Baroque Period came in many shapes and
sizes this is a late Styler this is a
baroque style loot so we call this one
an arch loot or a luto atir Bato it has
14 courses 14 pairs of strings so it
gets very very low
and these are the types of low notes
that you'd reach down to if you see that
there are letters below the tablature in
the case of Mr darling's midnight that
low note would sound like
so in context
[Music]
but as I said we're just going to repeat
that note
and it still sounds nice
and everything is the same until the
fourth measure of the B section instead
of playing
we have a little scale
your middle finger on the third fret it
says D on the sixth string then we play
an open a on the second that's the open
string
then while holding your second finger
down we play C D or two three
[Music]
and the A on the first means open so
and then that same chord we ended on the
first section all right now we have two
sections let's hear them again ready go
foreign
[Music]
there's one more section to the piece we
can call it the C-section and then
that'll be it here we have a on the
third string C on the second string so
zero two followed by f f is the fifth
fret remember on the first string
okay then D is the third fret on the
third string C open
second fret is C to the first measure
[Music]
going on we have second fret on the
fourth string open second string
D is the third fret of the first string
two zero
okay this is a funny one
we have f f d five five three and then
two zero or c a
so the second measure
let's play the first two measures slowly
ready
go
[Music]
so I'm picking up the pace here you
might need to pause and practice this a
bit to keep up at this point third
measure of the C-section open fourth
string that's a c is the second fret so
our chord
[Music]
like that A C or zero two on the first
string
[Music]
now we have c c a or two two zero
f d or five three
okay so measure four of the C-section
we have c a c two zero three
see again and then the chord we started
with
you'll notice I'm starting to pick up
the pace even more you're not meant to
necessarily learn the whole song
Perfectly in real time of this video
rewind replay practice come back and
you'll be able to do this for sure going
on on the first string CD 2 3 next
measure f f is five open third string so
zero five or AF
d c
DNA
three zero or a d a c with theater
second finger holding the third fret of
the third string
now really saves time if you can notice
patterns so this next chord we're about
to play we've already played it once so
try to notice that the second measure of
this section is the same chord c a d and
it even continues the same C A and now
the D the third fret of the sixth string
D on the second string with a little
scale d c d a
and again we have this chord which we
saw already in the third measure of this
section A D C it's a D major chord
a c d with a low e lower we call it a in
a tablature d c a d
last measure
C four two two
c a c and then the chord we started with
[Music]
again you won't learn this in real time
perfectly use the gear icon replay the
video
um practice the song a bit the point
here is not to master at first try it's
to understand how to read the notation
and then open up an infinite realm of
tablature to play from manuscripts from
400 years ago so practice what we just
learned walk through the piece until
this seems easy use my modern computer
versions if you have to but my
recommendation is don't use the numbers
use the letters the French tablature so
you can really play from The Originals
congrats on learning to play the 400
year old notes from Mr dowlins midnight
today next week in part two we're going
to learn how to play The rhythms and
then talk about which fingers you should
use if you enjoyed today's video make
sure you subscribe and hit the Bell so
you don't miss other videos I post like
this one if you want to help me make
more videos like this you can go to my
patreon and there you'll find lots of
behind the scenes content about what I'm
up to the videos I'm making performances
I'm giving and you'll receive rewards
like early viewing all my videos my CDs
and you can even get a private lesson
with me and lastly if you're interested
in learning classical guitar especially
at your own pace at home I have a
beginner online classical guitar course
called classical guitar Pro it's six
hours long 53 videos so I hope you'll
check that out until next time thanks
for watching
[Music]
foreign